FRIDAY JANUARY FOURTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER VISOR AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING IS BEING MADE OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS THERE'S ALSO
BEING TELEVISED. HOURS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDED TOURNAMENTS WERE
MASK AT ALL TIMES. ATTENDEES WAS
OFFER FRIEND FROM CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DESTROYERS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING. VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES MAY BE SUBJECTED
INDIVIDUALS REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. OF MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY. HERE CUNNINGHAM BANNACK
. BONTA FLORA GIPSON HERE LEE
YEAH MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS. RAMOS
RUBIO. HAVE YOU PUT OFF THEIR-
FLORA YOUR WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA THERE'S A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA. BERMAN CERVANTES
SECOND BY MISTER MATHIS THANK
YOU JOHN ALL MISTER SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM BENNETT.
BENNETT I BONTA BONTA HI FLORA
FLORA I GIPSON GIPSON HIGHLY ON
ME I MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE RAMOS
RAMOS I RUBIO THE APPROVED BY
THE APPROVED BY. PASSES OF THAT
MOST OF PASSED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE FOR YOUR PRESENCE HERE
I WILL REMAIN FOR A FEW MINUTES
- TO. PROVIDE OUR COLLEAGUES TO
JOIN.
OUR HELLO OF ISRAEL-
MISTER CAR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. I REALLY DON'T VERY GOOD THAT
IS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS VIDEO THE RULES COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED.